Hugh Jackman's final Wolverine outing, Logan,
arrived to a ton of critical acclaim — but
in addition to being a great film, it also
ushers in some huge changes for the X-Men
franchise.
From bidding farewell to a few of the franchise's
biggest stars, to showing us essentially how
the X-Men come to an end, Logan is a game
changer.
Here’s why Logan marks the end of an era
for superhero films.
The ‘old’ X-Men movies are over
Since debuting on the silver screen in 2000, the original X-Men cast
has popped up in pretty much every era of
the franchise ever since.
They anchored the original trilogy, returned
for the "future" part of Days of Future Past,
and had cameos everywhere in-between.
Now we have Jackman's Logan and Patrick Stewart's
Xavier back to to wrap it all up here.
And that's what this film does — it serves
as a coda for that era of the franchise.
As 20th Century Fox looks to keep the focus
on its younger lineup of stars with the eventual
sequel to X-Men: Apocalypse, this is the bookend
for the stories that started it all.
Jackman and Stewart are ex-X-Men
There's one thing that ties pretty much the
entire X-Men franchise together, regardless
of era, and that's Jackman.
Thanks to the fact that Wolverine doesn't
age, and apparently neither does Jackman.
Seriously, look at this guy!
Anyway, he's popped up in pretty much every
X-Men film except for Deadpool — and even
in that movie, his face still put in an appearance.
At this point, it's almost not an X-Men movie
without Wolverine.
But all that ends with Logan.
Jackman said:
"It is my last time.
It just felt like it was the right time to
do it."
So yeah, that’s pretty clear.
While the franchise has found success with
younger actors and new characters like Deadpool,
losing Jackman means the future of the X-Men
story has never been less clear.
Along with Jackman, the original Professor
Xavier — the guy who started the X-Men in
the first place — is also calling it quits.
Stewart is one of the most recognizable actors
in association with this franchise, and he
says he’s retiring, too.
James McAvoy has done a solid job of taking
up Stewart's mantle as young Xavier in the
prequel films, but for a certain generation
of fans, Stewart will always be Professor
X.
It's the final Wolverine solo film
The Wolverine spinoff franchise started out
on a rough note with X-Men Origins: Wolverine,
which was pretty much a train wreck.
But things got on the right path with the
samurai-tinged The Wolverine, which helped
properly set the stage for Logan.
But Logan marks the end of the Wolverine trilogy.
That's not to say Fox won't eventually recast
the role at some point, but it's still the
end of an era for Jackman's defining take
on the character.
It pushes the limits
The rave reviews all make one thing clear
when it comes to Logan: It's a fantastic movie,
and that isn't being graded on a curve against
the adjusted scale of comic book movies.
Logan is a brutal, beautiful, personal journey
that doesn't try to set world-ending stakes.
This is a small story that shows the near-limitless
potential for what can be done within the
format of a "superhero" movie.
Logan is ambitious in its simplicity, weaving
in elements from two-decades of films to tell
a story about a handful of people just trying
to do what's right.
It’s further proof superhero movies can
just be movies.
And good ones, to boot.
What comes next?
Logan wraps up the old saga of X-Men movies,
but also sets the stage for whatever Fox wants
to do next.
Is it another future-set story after Logan?
A 1990s-set film following the younger cast?
A new series of solo films?
No one knows just yet, but thankfully Logan
also blows the doors open in regards to what
you can accomplish and the types of stories
you can tell with the X-Men.
The possibilities are limitless for Fox to
do some truly creative things with the franchise.
We can't wait to see what comes next.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too!